*Clearing voice*
The rule is simple,
Skrattar du, förlorar du (You laugh, you lose)
How did this happen?
Oh!
What?
How?
Oh, my GAAAAAHH
What?
I am so confused how this happened.
You laugh, you lose.
Let's not laugh.
K, it's not that hard! It's not that hard! (Omae wa mou shindeiru)
He just went straight dolphin, out of nowhere!
Warning (mild ear rape)
Ooh, OOH!
Oh, my GAAAH
Brava, sei bellissima!
Wow!
That made me laugh.
I lost.
I lost, okay? Whatever.
Oh my god.
This is like, the oldest meme I can remember.
I was so confused when I saw this,
I'm like, what is, what is this joke?
Have you guys seen this? Is this too, is this too old for you?
Classic old, like -
flash-based -
It's back in the day when like these type of photoshop,
And they're like, "Wow! How did they DO that?"
This is a real -
It's a good - it's a classic. It's a classic meme.
It was a meme before it was meme. (what?)
Have you ever guys thought about that? You know...
There was a time...
...before memes were real.
IS THAT A MAN, RIDING A SHRIMP???
*R2D2 Screeching*
Gets me everytime man!
IS THAT A MAN RIDING A SHRIMP???
In Google Translate, I will proceed to type the characters, "E" and "Gu"!
They translate to: Return.
I shall copy them and paste them twice.
It changes to: Regret.
Once more: Eco-production!
Once more, Eiffel Tower!
And once more: DECEARING EGG!
What?
Once more is delicious breakfast.
And once more is: DECEARING EGG!
And once more is Delicious breakfast early evening soup.
Wait, is this real?
Okay, return.
Regret, ha ha ha!
Eco-production!
Wednesday eggpling!
Eco-production AGAIN!
Delicious breakfast!
Decearing egg!
Delicious breakfast early evening.
DECEARING EGG AGAIN.
Delicious breakfast early morning.
DECEARING EGO PREPARATION.
Delicios antiperspir oeujeugyeu (gibberish)
DeCEARING EGG EGOEGEGEGE
Delicious breakthroughs of deep-sea squeeze.
DECEARING EGG PREPARATION EGG...
Delicious soup with delicious soup with delicious soup.
Egu Egu Egu Egu Egu Egu Egu Egu Egu e guegu.
Japanese language is such a beautiful, complicated language.
You're asking me well, what animes I watch?
Yeah. Are you a voice actor?
Oh my god. It's a dude. (Nah, I'm not a voice actor.)
I can spot a dude from miles away because I respect WAHMEN,
Too much.
And there is no way a WAHMEN is gonna like Umaru-chan origina- ironically, okay? Alright?
Alright.
(In a male voice) Oh, I love Boku no Pico man!
That shit is the bomb!
*Deadass laughing*
That's the wrong music, look how happy he is.
I've never seen a man happier in my life!
He just found love!
Be happy.
Place some happy music.
We hate Trump and we wanna make a change!
How are we gonna do it?
Oh, my GAAAAH!!
It's a simple question: How? How are we gonna make a change?
How are we gonna do it?
Oh, WE HATE HIM!
OOOH, HE'S THE WORST.
HILLARY WAS THE BEST, man
*thug life song plays*
Too cool for dinner -
CALM DOWN MOM, I'M CLUTCHING.
I don't know if I would have believed you,
If you told me two years ago, before I made my HeForShe speech,
That we might have the first female president of The United States.
Please don't let me down America!
You're British. You're British!
You can't even vote!
You can't even vooote!
Thank you for watching another, "You laugh you lose"!
Did you laugh, or did you lose? Leave a comment down below.
If you recommend some clips down in the subreddit,
And do remember to daba-daba-daba-daba-du-subscribe!
Audience, family squad, Christian Channel, KACHOW!
#Squadfam out!
This has been PewDiePie, and BROFIST!
YEAH.
"Why are we still here?
Just to suffer?
Every night, I can feel my leg...
And my arm... even my fingers.
The body I’ve lost…
the comrades I’ve lost…
won’t stop hurting… It’s like they’re all still there.
You feel it, too, don’t you?”
Gotta stretch the videos to 10 minutes bois and wamen